AMERICAN EXPERIMENT THAT
INCLUDES LAW AND ORDER.
MORE ON THIS.
NO WONDER IN A NEW GALLUP POLL
ACTUAL AMERICANS POINT
IMMIGRATION IS THE ISSUE MOST
IMPORTANT TO THEM RIGHT BEHIND
OUR GOVERNMENT.
SO WHY AREN’T THE ACTIVISTS,
POLITICIANS, AND THE MAJORITY OF
THE MEDIA LISTENING?
HERE TO DEBATE, TOM HOMAN FORMER
ACTING DIRECTOR OF ICE AND A
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
LISA JOHNSON IS THE -- PROFESSOR
OF LAW AT GEORGETOWN UNIVERSITY.
IT’S GOOD TO HAVE YOU BOTH.
LET’S START WITH YOU, PROFESSOR.
I UNDERSTAND THERE’S A GREAT
HUMANITARIAN STORY TO BE TOLD.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS, INDEED
MILLIONS PROBABLY IN
CENTRAL AMERICA.
I SPENT A LOT OF TIME IN BOTH
EL SALVADOR AND GUATEMALA.
I KNOW THE PEOPLE WELL.
ANOTHER PLACE WELL.
BEAUTIFUL COUNTRIES, VERY
CORRUPT.
MOST OF THESE AREN’T
ASYLUM-SEEKERS.
THEIR ECONOMIC MIGRANTS.
BY OUR OWN BORDER PATROL DURING
OBAMA, MOST OF THEM WERE
OVERWHELMINGLY REJECTED.
WHY ISN’T THE METERING SLOWING
THIS DOWN SO WE CAN PROCESS
PEOPLE IN AN ORDERLY WAY?
WHY ISN’T THAT THE RIGHT WAY TO
GO?
>> FIRST I WOULD TAKE ISSUE THAT
THEY ARE ECONOMIC MIGRANTS.
IF YOU READ THE STATE DEPARTMENT
REPORT ON ANY OF THESE
COUNTRIES, THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE, SOME OF THE MOST
VIOLENT COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD.
GANGS HAVE, AS YOU NOTED, TAKEN
OVER THOSE COUNTRIES.
THEY ARE VERY CORRUPT AND VERY
DANGEROUS.
SO I WOULD SAY HAVE BEEN
PRACTICING IMMIGRATION LAW FOR
16 YEARS.
TEN YEARS AGO YES, I WAS SEEING
MORE ECONOMIC MIGRANTS.
NOW I BELIEVE I AM SEEING IN MY
CASELOAD TRUE ASYLUM-SEEKERS
FLAYING HORRIFIC GANG VIOLENCE.
>> Laura: THAT’S NOT ONE OF
THE -- THAT DOESN’T WORK ON
THEIR CREDIBLE FEAR CALCULATOR.
>> THOSE CASES ARE DIFFICULT TO
WIN.
THE WAY THAT ASYLUM LAW HAS BEEN
CONSTRUCTED.
>> Laura: YOU THINK IT SHOULD
BE MORE LENIENT THAN IT IS NOW?
>> I THINK GETTING TO THE
METERING, I’M GOING TO ADDRESS
YOUR ISSUE BUT GETTING TO THE
METERING ISSUE, WHEN WE ARE
HAVING PEOPLE AT PORTS OF ENTRY
RATHER THAN BEING ABLE TO CROSS
THE BORDER WHEREVER WHICH IS
HONESTLY BEING CHALLENGED.
WE ARE BASICALLY FORCING HUGE
POPULATION TO GO THROUGH A SMALL
ENTRY POINT.
IN THE PROCESS OF WAITING, THOSE
PEOPLE ARE SUBJECT TO VIOLENCE
WHILE THEY ARE WAITING.
I JUST INTERVIEWED A WOMAN LAST
WEEK WHO WAS RAPED WHILE WAITING
AT THE BORDER.
SHE HAD BEEN GANG RAPED 60 TIMES
IN THE PROCESS OF COMING TO THE
UNITED STATES.
SOME PEOPLE WILL TURN BACK.
I THINK IT’S A WAY THE
GOVERNMENT IS DISCOURAGING
PEOPLE FROM LEGITIMATELY
PRESENTING ASYLUM CLAIMS OF THE
BORDER THEY ARE ENTITLED TO
UNDER U.S. LAW.
>> Laura: TOM, I THINK THE
POLITICIANS HAVE REALLY BLOWN
THIS.
I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT HORRIFIC
THINGS -- WE KNOW HORRIFIC
THINGS HAVE HAPPENED TO
CHILDREN, WOMEN AND OTHERS.
THERE ARE CRIMINAL ELEMENTS
WITHIN THE MIGRANT CARAVAN.
WE KNOW THAT.
IT’S ALREADY BEEN PROVEN.
POLITICIANS REFUSED TO DO WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO TO MAKE THE
SYSTEM WORK.
THEY REFUSE.
RIGHT NOW I’M CAPITOL HILL, THE
LIGHTS ARE STILL ON.
THEY’RE NOT GOING TO DO
ANYTHING.
>> IT’S A POLITICAL PLOY BUT
THEY ARE DOING.
THEY GOT THIS GROUP OF 15, MOVE
THEM TO THE FRONT OF THE LINE
AHEAD OF 2500 PEOPLE THAT WERE
WAITING IN LINE PLAYING BY THE
RULES.
I’VE BEEN ENFORCING IMMIGRATION
LAW TWICE AS LONG AS YOU BEEN
PRACTICING IT AND I’M TELLING
YOU MOST ARE NOT LEGITIMATE
ASYLUM-SEEKERS.
VIOLENCE IS NOT A CLAIM FOR
ASYLUM.
90%.
WHAT THE POLITICIAN SHOULD BE
DOING RATHER THAN PULLING A
POLITICAL PLOY, THEY OUGHT TO BE
HERE IN WASHINGTON, D.C., FIXING
HERE IN WASHINGTON, D.C., FIXINGTHE LOOPHOLES IN OUR IMMIGRATION
THE LOOPHOLES IN OUR IMMIGRATION
LAWS THAT CAUSES THESE CARAVANS
TO EXIST IN THE FIRST PLACE.
I’VE BEEN ON THE HILL MANY TIMES
WITH THE SECRETARY, RAISE THE
ASYLUM BAR.
ADDRESS THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT.
GIVE I.C.E. DETENTION MONEY SO
IT’S NOT BACK TO CATCH AND
RELEASE.
IF THEY CLOSE THE LOOPHOLES,
THEY WILL STOP A LOT OF THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
IT’S NOT ABOUT PROTECTING THE
BORDER OR CLOTHING LOOPHOLES.
IT’S ABOUT TAKING ON THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
IT’S ABOUT POLITICS AT A PUBLIC
SAFETY NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> Laura: THIS IS JOE
SCARBOROUGH THIS MORNING WHO WAS
A REPUBLICAN.
I GUESS IS NO LONGER A
REPUBLICAN.
HE MADE THIS COMMENT.
LET’S WATCH.
>> I BELIEVE WHEN YOU COME TO
THE UNITED STATES, HE SHOULD
COME HERE ILLEGALLY.
THIS IS WHAT IS LOST IN THIS
ARGUMENT.
THESE PEOPLE COMING TO AMERICA
NOW ARE COMING HERE LEGALLY.
THAT IS LEGAL.
THEY ARE SEEKING REFUGEE STATUS.
AS FAR AS AMERICA BEING
OVERLOADED, THERE’S A NET
NEGATIVE FLOW BACK INTO MEXICO.
>> Laura: NET NEGATIVE FLOW
BACK INTO MEXICO.
IT’S MORE THE CENTRAL AMERICANS,
THE TRIANGLE FOLKS.
>> WE HAVE TO TAKE IT BACK TO
BASICS.
>> Laura: THEY ARE NOT
REFUGEES.
THEY ARE A SITE LEASE.
>> WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO THE
ISSUE.
IF THEY ARE ESCAPING FEAR AND
PERSECUTION FROM HONDURAS, THEY
ARE IN MEXICO.
THEY HAVE ESCAPED THE FEAR AND
PERSECUTION.
THEY ARE TO BE CLAIMING ASYLUM
IN THE FIRST SAFE PLACE THEY
COME DUE.
A PEOPLE DID TAKE MEXICO UP ON T
A PEOPLE DID TAKE MEXICO UP ON .
THIS IS ABOUT GETTING TO
UNITED STATES BECAUSE OF MAYBE
VIOLENCE.
>> Laura: I WANT THE PROFESSOR
TO REACT.
LOOKS LIKE THE UNITED STATES IS
GOING TO GIVE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO MEXICO AND
CENTRAL AMERICA IN PART TO TRY
TO HELP THEM KEEP PEOPLE IN
THEIR HOMELANDS AND ALSO GIVE
PEOPLE JOBS IN MEXICO.
WHAT IS IT, $4.6 BILLION THAT
CAME OUT TODAY.
THEY ARE NOT GIVING THAT MONEY
FOR NOTHING.
THAT MONEY IS GOING I THINK IN
PART TO SAY LOOK, YOU’VE GOT TO
STOP THIS FLOW COMING TO THE
UNITED STATES.
YOU NEED TO START INCORPORATING
PEOPLE IN MEXICO.
WHY AREN’T PEOPLE STAYING IN
MEXICO?
>> MEXICO IS NOT SAFE EITHER.
THE SAME GANGS AND CARTELS IN
HONDURAS, EL SALVADOR, GUATEMALA
ARE ALSO IN MEXICO.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK
EVERYONE SHOULD JUST BE ABLE TO
COME BECAUSE IT’S A BAD PLACE?
THERE’S A LOT OF BAD PLACES.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE AMERICAN
HISTORY IN OUR HISTORY AND
CENTRAL AMERICA WAS DONE OVER
THE PAST 100 YEARS, WE HAVE
CREATED A LOT OF THE REFUGEE
CRISIS.
>> Laura: SO IT’S KIND OF A
REPARATION THING.
>> WE SHOULD BE SENDING MONEY TO
THOSE COUNTRIES TO HELP
ESTABLISH SAFER GOVERNMENTS,
MORE ACCOUNTABLE GOVERNMENTS.
BUT IT’S ALSO, THAT’S NOT GOING
HAPPEN OVERNIGHT.
IN THE MEANTIME, WE DO HAVE
THOUSANDS OF PARTICULARLY WOMEN
AND CHILDREN WHO ARE FLEEING FOR
THEIR LIVES.
THAT MUST BE ADDRESSED.
WE HAVE AN INTERNATIONAL
OBLIGATION TO ADDRESS IT.
>> Laura: INTERNATIONAL
OBLIGATION.
TOM.
>> THE FACT OF THE MATTER, WHEN
I WAS I.C.E. DIRECTOR WE REMOVE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE FROM
GUATEMALA, HUNTER ASSIGNED
EL SALVADOR TO THE COUNTRY EVERY
DAY THERE’S NO CLAIM OF FEAR.
THESE CLAIMS ARE FALSE.
VERY FEW MEXICANS CLAIM ASYLUM.
SO I DON’T AGREE WITH MEXICO NOT
BEING A SAFE PLACE.
WE DON’T HAVE MEXICANS CLAIMING
ASYLUM.
WE’VE GOT TO GET BACK TO THE
BASICS OF WHAT’S GOING ON HERE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
COME TO THIS COUNTRY FOR A
BETTER LIFE.
CAN’T BLAME THEM FOR THAT BUT
YOU CAN’T WANT TO BE PART OF THE
GREATEST COUNTRY ON OR ABOUT NOT
RESPECT HIS LOSS.
YOU CAN’T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
>> Laura: SKIPPING THE LINE.
THEY ARE ALSO USING THE SYSTEM.
AS IT EXISTS TODAY, THE SYSTEM
IS RIDICULOUS, AND THE FACT THAT
THIS CROWD ON CAPITOL HILL WILL